les templiers d'elancourt ont repris la
compétition ce samedi 18 janvier les
élans courtois accueillis au complexe
sportif europe les léopards de roi
l'occasion pour les joueurs yvelinois de
montrer les muscles et le potentiel de
l'équipe dans cette deuxième division
comme tout champion l'humble a débuté
quoi on est dans une bonne phase à bruz
être dans une bonne dynamique
une bonne dynamique pour bien débuter la
saison quand c'est important de bien
commencer donc voilà c'est commencer par
une victoire ce serait bien pour la
suite des événements va dire mais le
match ne tourne pas en faveur des îles
en courtois les joueurs locaux sont
dominés et perdre la partie sur le score
de 22 à 9
l'objectif de montée en fin de saison
n'est pas encore remise en question mais
les joueurs devront trouver rapidement
des automatismes pour remporter des
victoires
il ya un mélange d'anciens et de juniors
qui venait qui sont issus des des
sections jeunes qui venaient pollué de
fond la première saison en senior
donc ça change un peu donc voilà frei un
temps d'adaptation
voilà quoi faut qu'après je pense que
quand on recule en moi qui pourront bien
là pour apporter à décrypter les
templiers joueront leur deuxième match
de la saison le samedi 1er février
contre les myrmidon de savigny-le-temple
toujours à domicile une équipe qui a
remporté son premier match de la saison
contre nantes